so cancer is fundamentally a disease of
the genome I mean the reason a tumor
grows is because the cells in that tumor
have picked up glitches they've picked
up mutations they picked up changes in
the DNA that make those cells grow out
of control it's like pressing and
accelerate in a car and just keep it
going it's just grows and grows and
grows and grows and the reason why is
because something's broken in the genome
and so what's happened in the past ten
years in particular since the end of the
human genome project is the recognition
that we can read out the genome the
sequence of the tumors DNA and gain
insights from that tumor with respect to
what have been the DNA changes that have
led to that those cells becoming a
cancer and that is being done in a very
large scale in many countries around the
world here included in the United States
we're literally very defined cancers are
being studied hundreds of specimens are
being collected from people and those
genomes of those tumors are being read
out and have all that data be put on the
internet for scientists to be able to
collect it all and analyze it and we are
learning a tremendous amount about
cancer and many very interesting and
surprising ways and among the many
things that are happening is it's giving
us insights about how to better classify
different types of cancer and different
subtypes of cancer and I often make the
points that some of the earliest
implementation of genomics in the
medical situation is going to be with
cancer and it's already happening now
and I think it's gonna grow considerably
where I think standard of care for many
types of cancer are gonna be get that
tumor read out its DNA sequence its
genome and based on what you've seen
what's wrong with that tumor not by
looking at it under a microscope only or
by looking at it in a sort of a gross
fashion but actually looking inside its
blueprint you will be able to have a
much better way of deciding what types
of treatments to pursue and have a much
better idea about what's wrong in that
kind of tumor and some of those things
will also be very helpful for leading to
possibly new developments of therapy
you